okay so invincible was by far one of the
best superhero shows of last year at a
time when disney are often accused of
playing their mcu shows too safe
invincible came along and completely
knocked it out the park the series was
filled with over-the-top gore amazing
action scenes and also several twists
and turns throughout that made it a must
watch at the heart of it was omniman
who's arguably the most memorable aspect
of the entire show but why is he the
perfect villain for the amazon series
well throughout this video that's what
we're going to be going over now because
of this there will be some spoilers so
if you haven't had a chance to check out
the full series then i highly recommend
that you check out now if you agree with
us then please hit the thumbs up button
and also don't forget to subscribe for
videos like this every day without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into why omniman is the
perfect villain
okay so invincible episode 1 introduced
us to the titular character and his
father omniman superheroes are a dime a
dozen at this point and if you weren't
familiar with the source material then
you might think that this was just
another carbon copy of superman
throughout the initial entry we watched
as mark came to grips with his powers
and also learned some of his father's
origin story you would tell that he was
a protector of peace and justice who
came from the planet veltrum this planet
was supposed to be not too dissimilar to
our own but those that lived there had
abilities far beyond what we have
omniman tells mark that belgium was
somewhat a utopia that had achieved
perfection through taking no tolerance
towards murder and war with no conflict
to tackle the high council decree that
their society shouldn't become
complacent and they sent their people
out into the stars in order to help the
universe achieve the perfection that
they had omniman or rather nolan as he
calls himself says that he and several
scientists travel through the cosmos
improving planets and the life forms on
them he was apparently given the job of
helping earth and it became his second
home after he met a woman named debbie
the pair settled down had a kid and he's
protected the planet ever since now
though he looks like henry cavill in
justice league before the vfx work the
two couldn't be more dissimilar and we
learn that this is actually a lie come
the season finale or issue 11 in the
comics we learn the truth and it goes
down worse than joss whedon at a
feminist rally that's two joss whedon
jokes back to back
now this is one of the major things that
makes omniman so fascinating we live in
a society where people are often propped
up as heroes however over time we learn
that the truth is far more shadowy than
that and they often aren't all they
appear to be i think the song says sojo
by murray head sums this up perfectly
and it's become somewhat of a cultural
icon written in the 70s prior to richard
nixon's resignation the tune was based
on a documentary in which a presenter
asked people in a small town what they
thought about the president even in the
face of conclusive evidence and proof
they still showed their support and this
was further likened to the story of joe
jackson whose name appears in the title
of the song during the 1920s joe was a
baseball player that reportedly took a
bribe to lose the final of the world
series and people at the stadium chanted
say it ain't so joe our heroes are our
heroes and sometimes it's difficult to
see them any other way even if they're
shown not to be i think that omniman
perfectly symbolizes this and come the
end of the first episode i saw people
who are unaware of the twist still
rallying for him in the post-credits
scene of episode 1 we watch him brutally
massacre the guardians of the globe and
upon its release many people believe
that this was mind control a clone or
something else they did anything to save
the hero and all that he stood for come
episode 8 though we learned the truth
and mark very much has this reaction too
he can't believe his dad's like this and
speaking from personal experience it's
difficult for us to see the flaws in our
parents even when they do bad i'd say
it's way easier to forgive them than it
is to forgive a friend and this is very
much cemented in the pairs exchange
throughout the finale we learn what
belgium really stands for and that it
actually forced its population to fight
one another in order to weed out the
weak they killed fifty percent of all
velcro mites and all that was left when
they just settled was the best of the
best of the best sir the high council
then decided to send out the world
conquering committee and due to their
enhanced strength they took over several
civilizations in order to build an
empire those that surrendered became
enslaved and their planets were picked
dry of all their resources those that
resisted were wiped out and the veltrome
empire spanned the galaxy however over
time their forces were spread too thin
and thus they had to devise a new plan
rather than just attacking planets
they'd send in a trojan horse who'd take
the form of a hero our great villains
are always great because you can see the
positive aspects of their plans nolan
doesn't really see himself as the bad
guy and he also discusses the benefits
that come with earth joining the empire
though they'd picked the planet clean
this would take thousands and thousands
of years and in that time humanity would
prosper beltram would give us the
advanced medical care that they
developed they'd end war on the planet
and everyone on earth would live in
peace and harmony until we became
extinct which sounds nice i guess now
you can definitely see the benefits of
it and nolan in his mind was very much
doing right by us and right by his own
people he started to slip into society
and he picked a pet and deborah who he
decided to raise his son with because
voltron my dna is so pure it completely
overruled the human aspects of him and
mark gained all the abilities that his
dad has nolan's plan was to raise him to
become as merciless as he was but
humanity had other ideas and that kind
of takes us to the battle between the
pair which spans the planet it's bloody
brutal has thousands of deaths in it and
it's clear that nolan completely
outmatches his son there's some
absolutely unforgettable moments in the
episode such as when mark saves a pilot
and then omniman crushes his head just
to show how insignificant we are he also
forces his son's face through a train
and yeah hard to get this image out your
head now omniman's just impossible to be
on a physical level but what the series
does perfectly is that it allows him to
be defeated on an emotional one
throughout the entry nolan explains that
his vulture might get older they age
more slowly and that mark's lifespan
will last for thousands and thousands of
years after pummeling his son to an inch
of his life nolan asks his son what
he'll have in thousands of years when
everything is gone and he says he'll
have him it completely breaks nolan and
we get a flashback to a time when he
likely first saw the good in humanity
watching the smile on his son's face as
he plays baseball makes him see him as a
person instead of an object of war and
it completely breaks the character
throughout his entire life he's been
told that having emotions is weak and
that the weak must perish however for
once he sees things from another point
of view and this completely changes his
perspective villains like the best
heroes are often that way because
they're flawed and we can see in them
aspects of ourselves i'm sure many of us
growing up have got caught up in an
ideal and because of this we've been
jerks to people who don't agree with
what we think is right whether it's
religion lifestyle choices or just
general attitudes we can often end up
seeing things only in black and white
which ultimately leads to our values
being questioned sometimes we agree with
a counter-argument and change and often
this is for the better this is what
nolan very much represents and why he's
the perfect villain he has a stance and
takes it but he can also become weakened
in that viewpoint when the right thing
is presented to him however that doesn't
mean he changes completely and nolan
flies off into space leaving a single
teardrop behind he's clearly broken and
if you've read the comics then you'll
know the arc of redemption that he
somewhat goes on i don't want to spoil
it as i know you guys might still want
some surprises but omniman is the
perfect villain because of the change
that we see in him he's very much a
father figure that is set in his ways
but after he sees the good in his
children he decides to change it's
something that's been seen in darth
vader and it's a motif that works over
and over again because it's always based
on emotions rather than physical
strength omniman is one of the most
memorable superheroes to come out in the
last 20 years or so and he perfectly
deconstructs what it would be like to
have the power of a god that only deals
in absolutes he's questioned and then
changes and this very much makes us
wonder if we would be strong enough to
change our minds if we could do whatever
we wanted because of these reasons
omniman is fascinating and looking back
at invincible he's the perfect villain i
hope you enjoyed the video and i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we're on a competition right now
and giving away three copies of the june
box on the 28th of feb and all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so if that's
you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want some else to
watch then make sure you check out one
of our videos on screen right now
especially the perfect scene playlist we
talk about lots of things that we love
it's very positive very uplifting we
don't like to moan that much so
hopefully it'll cheer you up and make
your day a bit better without the way
thanks for sitting through the video
i've been paul let's see on the next one
take care peace